alors nous poursuivrons avec le dr karl
weiss microbiologiste et spécialiste des
maladies infectieuses à l'hôpital
général juif de montréal dr weiss
bonsoir alors commençons autour de ces
controverses avec le vaccin
d'astrazeneca à ce débat sur son
efficacité pour les personnes de plus de
65 ans il ya autant d'opinions que
d'experts vous irez ou à peu près là il
ya le comité fédéral d'immunisation dis
qu'il est pas efficace teresa tam de la
santé publique du canada dit donnons le
plus de vaccins ou plus de gens possible
le québec n'a pas tranché l'ontario dit
non vous est ce que vous diriez qu'on va
gaspiller ce vaccin si on le donne aux
plus de 65 ans alors voilà ce qu'on sait
sur le vaccin d'astrazeneca d'abord
c'est un vaccin qui est moins efficace
pour prévenir une maladie symptomatique
comparé au vaccin de pfizer et moderne a
donc l'efficacité pour les 18 à 64 ans
est d'environ 65% va mettre les chiffres
ronds par rapport à 95 %
la deuxième chose qu'on sait c'est qu'il
faut les administrés à peu près 12
semaines la deuxième dose après la
première dose
sinon il ya peut-être même une perte
d'efficacité la troisième chose qu'on
sait c'est que chez les plus de 65 ans
l'ex témoins à tel point que par exemple
des pays comme l'allemagne ont décidé de
ne pas administrer la france
initialement
les etats-unis n'ont pas mis sur leur
marché actuellement
et enfin le dernier point c'est qu'on
sait que c'est un vaccin qui est moins
efficace entre autres contre le variant
sud africains qu'on ne commence à avoir
au québec entre autres en abitibi et le
dernier point qui est peut-être un peu
plus inquiétant mais sur lequel on n'a
pas beaucoup de données à gap
il semblerait qu'en europe beaucoup de
travailleurs de la santé aussi bien en
france qu'en allemagne et eu des effets
secondaires après l'administration du
vaccin alors je le dis sous toute
réserve parce que j'ai rien vu de
publier dans une revue scientifique mais
il ya des publications qui commencent à
sortir là dessus mais je vais pas parler
de la grande bretagne qui l'a
administré à forte dose à toute une
population tout à fait alors la
grande-bretagne évidemment c'est un
vaccin britannique donc ils ont
administré des vaccins qui a quand même
son efficacité il faut pas négliger ce
qu'il faut quand même pas penser que le
vaccin d'astrazeneca ne fonctionne pas
donc il a quand même une certaine
protection sur la maladie sévère mais
ils ont aussi administrée dodoz en
grande bretagne de d'autres axes la
question qu'on doit se poser au canada
c'est que si on nous avions absolument
aucun autre vaccin disponible et que le
seul vaccin sur la planète était celui
d'astrazeneca
je pense que personne ne se poserait la
moindre question sur son utilisation
le problème c'est que nous avons
plusieurs choix nous avons des choix
entre des vaccins qui sont efficaces à
plus de 95% et un vaccin qui semble être
moins efficace et dont la protection
pour les personnes plus âgées est sujet
à débat
ce qui dans le contexte vu qu'on a un
choix on est devant on devrait plutôt
s'orienter vers le choix le plus
avantageux est judicieux pour le canada
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'inconnues face
à toute cette campagne de vaccination
avait en fait à partir du moment où on a
approuvé ces médecins ces vaccins on
savait qu'ils avaient beaucoup
d'inconnues n'est ce pas sur leur
efficacité sur s qui est ce que la
maladie seraient transmises quand même
combien de temps dure l immunité
il ya beaucoup beaucoup d'inconnues et
compte tenu du fait que nos
gouvernements doivent lutter contre ce
variant ces variants qui sont déjà chez
nous au pays au québec partout au canada
est ce que on ne devrait pas faire fi ou
en tout cas être un peu moins sévère à
cheval sur l'étiquette scientifique et
donner le plus de vaccins en plus de
gens possible bon alors ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que les vaccins sont très
efficaces les vaccins demande errements
et par exemple commencent à montrer leur
efficacité là où ils ont été attribués
de façon importante donc les vaccins
sont très très bons on n'a pas coupé les
coins ronds dans l'approbation de ces
vaccins bas donc moi j'encourage très
fortement tous les canadiens à se faire
vacciner le plus vite possible si on
leur offre le vaccin je pensais le
premier point il ya bien sûr des
incertitudes sur l'efficacité des
vaccins pour toutes les strates d'âge
pour les gens qui ont des maladies sous
jacentes
combien de temps nous prenons notre
protection va durer est-ce que les gens
qui ont mis le vaccin peuvent continuer
à transmettre le virus la réponse est
oui mais probablement
beaucoup moins que ceux qui n'ont pas eu
le vaccin dont on commence à avoir des
réponses actuellement c'est un vaccin
nouveau faut aussi remettre ça en
perspective
en moins d'un an quasiment c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire c'est le
dire et c'est la plus grande victoire
probablement de la médecine moderne
c'est d'avoir dans un an dans une
pandémie en moins d'un an réussir à
faire un vaccin efficace qu'on a déjà
administrer faut pas l'oublier à plus de
200 millions de personnes sur la planète
mais on est vraiment dans une course
contre la montre contre les variants
n'est ce pas là ces vaccins contre ça
tout à fait alors on a deux automne à
une auto vaccin on a eu nos taux variant
et les deux sont sur la ligne de départ
et vont faire la course et celle qui va
gagner va nous permettre de sortir d'un
confinement et je vous dirais d'un
environnement de couvre-feu de consignes
mans difficile tout simplement parce que
si on arrive à vacciner beaucoup de gens
rapidement les variants n'arriveront pas
ce je vous dirais s'immiscer dans la
société se répandre et créer encore plus
de problèmes
oui parce que c'est vrai oui c'est les
marioles emporte as tu une troisième
vague potentiellement plus forte que les
deux premières ben c'est une troisième
voie que ce cas sera plus fort
possiblement que non parce que il ya
quand même des gens qu'ils sont protégés
les vaccins ont une efficacité envers
les variants donc on risque
on peut avoir beaucoup de cas mais des
cas beaucoup moins sévères par exemple
donc moins de gens aux soins intensifs
moins de gens qui décèdent
on le voit déjà au québec dans les ch et
celle des dans les centres de soins
prolongés ou on a on a donné beaucoup de
vaccins
le nombre de maladies sévères et quand
même à la tendance lourde vers le bas
donc l'efficacité de la vaccination est
déjà là et les pays qui ont vacciné
énormément sortent des études quasiment
tous les jours sur l'efficacité d'une
campagne de vaccination rapide à
l'échelle populationnelle dr weiss merci
beaucoup avait plaisir à entrer